quand j'étais petit
j'ai eu un rêve celui d'être dans
pourtant nous ne naissons pas tous égaux
nous n'avons pas tous les mêmes chances
les enfants ne savent pas ces choses là
j'étais une petite fille noire ma mère
était femme de ménage et mon père était
maçon
pour danser j'ai dû me battre contre les
préjugés et contre les noms
ma mère m'a permis de partir au bo
chabal academy en russie les portes ne
mettait pas de grandes ouvertes alors
comment ce fils devenu danseuses en fait
dans la vie j'ai souvent forcé des
portes et parfois j'ai dit on construire
finalement mon père et moi on fait le
même métier lui construit des maisons et
moi je construis des portes plus
sérieusement je me suis toujours
interrogé sur les normes et notre
rapport à celle ci dans les ballets
classiques comme dans la culture
populaire le blanc évoque bien la pureté
innocence le noir évoque le mal le
désespoir la mort ce qui me fascine
c'est de comprendre comment on a
transposé cette idée à l'être humain le
cygne blanc et le cygne noir sont la
même personne c'est l'un des rôles les
plus prestigieux du ballet classique et
on retrouve souvent des dents ses
épaules blanche dans ce rôle on ne
demande pas la danseuse qui l'incarnent
de se maquiller la points noirs et son
costume suffit à représenter son alter
ego noir en revanche il est d'usagé dans
de nombreuses compagnies de maquillé en
noir les rôles secondaires comme dans la
danse des crayons renommée la danse des
enfants dans la bayadère ou comme le
rôle du mort dans petrouchka alors la
question est la suivante comment les
normes véhicules tels parfois nos
préjugés est ce normal d'être un
individu blanc hétérosexuel riches ou
est ce un privilège cela dépend
essentiellement des barrières que la
société imposera à ceux et à celles qui
ne répondent pas à ces critères il y a
plus de pauvres sur terre on pourrait
donc penser que la norme serait d'être
pauvre pourtant la société privilégier
les riches en leur donnant accès à une
meilleure éducation en leur permettant
de vivre dans des villes où les loyers
sont élevés et où se concentrent les
opportunités professionnelles
une formation de danse classique en
france à avoise et les 60000 euros en
incluant l'éducation
l'internât les familles d'accueil le
week-end le coût des points que des
justes quand de danse ainsi que les
cours particuliers
soixante mille euros c'est une somme
astronomique quand on sait que le smic
est d'environ 1200 euros et la france
est plutôt un bon élève puisse calandre
à new york il faudra compter plus de
150000 à 200000 euros si vous ne
bénéficiez pas d'une bourse lorsqu'on
est privilégiée on n'affronte pas à ces
problématiques et de ce fait on ne les
voit pas donc notre société a tendance à
accentuer l'écart qui existe entre les
privilégiés et ceux qui ne le font pas
prenons un exemple un peu caricatural de
7 à la hauteur d'une poignée de porte
personne dans cette salle ne se
questionne sur cette norme étant donné
que tout le monde ici mesure entre un
mètre cinquante et de m pourtant les
personnes de petite taille mesure en
moyenne 1 m 20
d'autres à mobilité réduite ne peuvent
pas développer la main force pour
actionner une poignée des lois inclusive
ont réglé cette question afin de
permettre à ces personnes de se déplacer
sans l'aide d'un tiers
cela paraît évident mais voyez plutôt
cet exemple
les normes ne doivent pas s'adapter à
chacun d'entre nous mais elles doivent
inclure tout le monde les normes ne sont
pas figées elles doivent évoluer avec
notre société il en est de même dans le
milieu du ballet
malgré son aspect traditionalistes
élitiste il doit évoluer avec son époque
et ses pratiques rétrogrades seront
amenés à disparaître partout dans le
monde alors comment faire évoluer les
normes et pourquoi sont elles si
difficile à affronter
il ya ici deux éléments importants
premièrement ce que la norme privilégie
pas penser qu'il perdait quelque chose
c'est cette langue disparaît c'est cela
peut être vrai mais pensez à cette
question que père celui qui est
privilégié par la norme et que galles
celui qui a été défavorisé par la norme
il existe de nombreux exemples de nant
qui ont disparu et qui nous scandalise
ray tous aujourd'hui du moins je
l'espère d'autres exemples de normes qui
font l'actualité parce qu'elle canalise
une proportion toujours plus large de la
société
deuxièmement le cadre légal doit évoluer
pour fixer ce nom afin d'empêcher ceux
qui ont bénéficié d' agir en toute
impunité
mais il appartient à chacun d'entre nous
d'entendre raison et de ne pas
s'enfermer dans des idées préconçues
dans les normes du passé
moi je suis dans le sas et ce mot
signifie que je ne devrais pas
m'exprimer au delà de mes pointes
la première porte que je veux construire
démocratisons les arts classiques
le futur benzi la future civic guillem
ou le prochain mozart habite peut-être à
trappes dans un bain mètres carrés dans
les milieux artistiques
et dans le ballet en particulier il y à
une compétition intense
c'est dur je ne vous le cache pas alors
quand j'allais à la danse je savais que
je devais être meilleur que mes
camarades
pour réussir il fallait que je me
distingue pas mental on y lit à de
nombreux rapports de force entre les
danseurs entre les maîtres de ballet qui
nous coach et la direction artistique et
il existe partout dans la société
je dirais que le ballet rend ces
rapports de force plus violent pour
plusieurs raisons c'est un milieu
traditionaliste élitiste les places se
vendent entre 50 et 250 euros dans la
plupart des grandes compagnies nous
danseurs n'avons pourtant que des
contrats à durée déterminée plutôt
précaire alors que nos supérieurs ont
souvent des contrats bien protégés cette
asymétrie alimente nomertin dans ces
milieux il n'était pas rare
de voir de nombreux abus passés sous
silence
on se tait pour ne pas perdre notre
contrat on se tait pour ne pas laisser
paraître nos faiblesses il n'ya souvent
pas de ressources humaines dans les
compagnies pas de syndicat on est livrés
à nous-mêmes dans ce métier alors que
faire quand une amie me dis qu'en de ses
supérieurs l'embrasser de force a abusé
d'elle ou quand une autre sombre dans
l'anorexie parce qu'on lui a demandé de
perdre du poids
ces phrases ont été dit pendant des
répétitions
rentrer tes fesses de négresse tu danses
comme une pour ma part j'ai
vécu récemment le racisme et j'ai décidé
de ne pas rester silencieuse on ne
devrait pas la prendre parce qu'elle est
noire
voilà ce que ma supérieure allie deux
mois après une audition ce sont ces
comportements intolérables que je ne
supporte plus et que je souhaite
combattre aujourd'hui alors si comme moi
vous avez été victimes de situations
d'abus si vous avez subi des violences
psychologiques ou physiques
je vous en supplie parlez-en trouver une
personne de confiance et parlez-lui mais
ne restez pas dans le silence
j'ai osé parler en prenant le risque de
ne plus jamais relancé parce que la
plupart des directeurs de compagnies se
connaissent et que les nouvelles vont
vite dans le milieu du ballet mais après
avoir parlé de mon histoire
les témoignages que j'ai reçus m'ont
donné la certitude qu'il y a quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas dans ce
milieu et je ne crois pas que le ballet
soit un cas isolé
notre société même si beaucoup de
progrès ont été faits à une tendance
mécanique à promouvoir les comportements
agressifs on prend par la force
on exploite jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait
plus rien on produit en détruisant en
polluants en tuant on a notre part de
responsabilité dans tout cela mais
aujourd'hui on en a conscience et on
peut adresser ces questions à l'humanité
toute entière
je me suis demandé quelle était ma
responsabilité pourquoi je devrais
parler des discriminations que j'ai
subies et ma réponse est une évidence
c'est la deuxième porte que j'ai
construite pour nous libérer de cette
omerta
je le dois
parce que je le peux parce que si je ne
fais rien rien ne changera la
responsabilité comme la vôtre ne se
limite pas aux normes elle ne se limite
pas au confort individuel
il y avoue et il y à nous
parler pour ceux qui ne le peuvent pas
osé pour ceux qui n'osent pas
chacun a la possibilité d'améliorer les
conditions de vie de quelqu'un d'autre
et chaque pas en avant vers un monde
plus juste plus équitable compte
je me suis attaqué à la plus grande et
prestigieuse compagnie de danse
d'allemagne non pas pour moi mais pour
toutes ces petites filles et tous ces
petits garçons qui partagent le même
rêve que le mien après avoir cherché à
résoudre le problème en interne j'ai
pris conscience que les institutions ont
tendance à les enterrer au lieu de les
résoudre préférant garder la face que
d'agir et de changer pourtant toutes ces
institutions sont têtes de gens comme
vous et moi
alors si nous pouvons changer si nous
pouvons nous améliorer elles peuvent
aussi c'est une question d'éducation
c'est une question de volonté
j'ai subi le racisme je me suis exprimé
j'ai brisé le silence et porter plainte
pour que finalement mon expérience soit
entendue et qu'une réconciliation et
était possible
pardonner c'est se donner une chance
d'avancer et c'est la troisième porte
que je vous souhaite de franchir